en général les juges de la Cour suprême
sont discrets ils ne veulent pas trop
attirer l'attention mais depuis quelques
mois c'est tout le contraire pour le
juge Russell Brown c'est que Monsieur
Brown s'est retrouvé au milieu d'une
chicane qui a dégénéré dans un chicotel
de l'Arizona en janvier un peu tout le
monde avait bu les esprits sont des
chauffer des taloches ce sont données et
le Conseil canadien de la magistrature
avait institué une enquête pour
inconduite sur le juge Brown mais il a
coupé court à cette démarche en
annonçant sa démission hier résultat on
aura probablement jamais le fin mot de
cette histoire comme le hasard fait
souvent bien les choses en politique le
juge en chef de la Cour suprême Richard
Wagner était en conférence de presse
maintenant c'est rare qui donne des
conférences de presse mais il fait au
moins une fois par année pour le bilan
de l'année et il a commenté le processus
d'enquête sur les juges on écoute
si une plainte sérieuse elle va être
traitée de façon sérieuse mais de façon
efficace il faut avoir un régime de
protection à la fois pour protéger
l'indépendance judiciaire on peut pas
évoquer un juge parce qu'on n'aime pas
une de ses décisions c'est fondamentales
démocratie donc c'est juste pour des
motifs vraiment qui par exemple vont à
l'encontre des principes d'éthiques mais
il faut avoir un processus qui soit qui
soit quand même rigoureux et qu'on peine
d'être pas des appels incidents des
révisions judiciaires multiples
simplement pour gagner du temps parce
que ça ça mène la crédibilité du système
dans l'esprit des citoyens
et en même temps on se pose la question
est-ce que le processus devrait pas être
un peu plus transparent aussi François
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
là on va on va jamais savoir ce qui
s'est vraiment passé parce que je
prononce qu'on comprend la démission
méfait à l'enquête est-ce que ça devrait
pas être histoire un peu plus sur ce qui
s'est passé avec le jugement Françoise
oubliez ça là peut-être que oui vous
devrez mais ça arrivera pas alors ça
c'est une des choses moi j'ai toujours
compris par contre que le Conseil de la
magistrature qui fait qui procède
parfois des enquêtes mais un comité sur
pied pour enquêter faut faire attention
parce qu'il reçoive des plaintes il les
enquêtes ça va pas dire qu'on va avoir
une enquête formelle sur dans tous les
cas parce que des fois ça peut être des
gens qui sont juste frustrés
effectivement d'une décision comme dit
si bien le juge en chef Wagner on se
débarrasse pas d'un juge parce que
quelqu'un est pas content de sa décision
si on veut protéger le concept
d'indépendance judiciaire mais on peut
pas commencer à envoyer ça de façon
public faire en sorte que ça devient ça
devient un cirque ce qu'on voit le
présentement avec dans notre arme moi je
voudrais pas voir ça avec avec nos jus
c'est une des forces de notre système à
mon point de vue le fait que nos juges
ne soient pas élus qui soit là jusqu'à
75 ans donc la pression politique
fonctionne pas sur un réseau et dans ce
contexte ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
eu le nom politique mais une fois une
fois nommé ces gens-là sont extrêmement
indépendants de leur pensée juridique
par contre le juge en chef quand tu
parles d'avoir des enquêtes plus rapides
je faisais quand même depuis janvier que
ces histoires là traînaient et c'est pas
bon pour la magie la magistrature dans
son ensemble moi je vous avoue comme
comme avocate lorsque j'ai entendu
parler de ce colos du jugement ma
première réflexion ça a été de me dire
voyons donc mais mais excusez maintenant
qui est plus juste j'ai le droit de dire
mais quel imbécile va se mettre dans
cette position
et risquer sa carrière puis les juges à
qui je parlais tout au long de ma
carrière me dit toujours ce qui trouvait
le plus difficile dans leur rôle c'est
le fait qu'ils deviennent presque comme
des moines des moines ils ont pu le
droit nécessairement en fait il ne se
donne plus le droit de vivre
pratiquement normalement dans des
cercles d'amis même si juge Wagner a
essayé d'amener la cour près du peuple
de se promener à travers le pays il spa
de licence à ces juges d'aller en partie
dans le bord du point de vue
les allégations à mon endroit sont
fausses sont non fondés
juste le fait de retrouver là tu te mets
dans une position qui peut être parfois
dangereuse convaincu qu'on rétrospective
il doit se dire mon Dieu j'aurais dû
juste bifurquer puis m'en aller
directement vers ma chambre je pensais
jamais en état de personne sympathique
je fais simplement dire ça parce que en
même temps juste les histoires qui se
promenaient même si on pense pas que
c'est c'est lui qui était fautif dans
l'histoire fait en sorte que ça jette du
discrédit sur la course suprême dans son
ensemble sur les autres vues puis en
passant le fait de démissionne aussi il
y a des gens qui vont dire c'est parce
qu'il avait peur de l'enquête qui allait
commencer et puis il a 56 ans je pense
il aurait pu être là encore pendant
environ une vingtaine d'années donc
c'est c'est quelque chose quand même
c'est des missions ok automatiquement
Michel là Monsieur Trudeau va falloir
qu'il nomme un autre juge puis est-ce
que il peut orienter
idéologiquement la Cour suprême en
hommage
nous on pense au Canada qu'on est à
l'abri de ça on est pas aux États-Unis
où les nominations sont carrément
beaucoup plus politiques qu'ici ici ici
on espère puis on s'est doté de comité
qui devrait normalement
présenter des candidatures qui sont à
l'abri d'influence politique c'est en
tout cas on veut continuer d'y croire
cela dit le juge Wagner ce matin il y a
aussi fait son point de presse pour
réitérer abondamment le fait
qu'actuellement au pays il y a 80 postes
vacants de juges et ça c'est ça nous
redit encore on le dit ici à l'émission
à quel point le gouvernement Trudeau
soit qu'il est très mal habile dans ces
nominations ou soit qui est fait pas
combien de poste de nomination qui
devrait être faite par le gouvernement
qui ne sont pas faites et dans le cas de
la justice c'est ça à mon avis tellement
important que ces nominations là ce
succèdent à un rythme régulier pourquoi
pour effectivement s'assurer de
l'accessibilité de notre système de
justice incluant la course prime
normalement ils sont 9 jours 9 jours il
faut que ce soit un chiffre impair 7 ou
5 mais là il serait rendu à assiéger à 5
juges en termes de de décision juste
impartial nuancer etc qui protège
effectivement
l'interprétation des lois en vertu de la
Constitution puis il y a des lois
importantes qui s'en viennent la loi 21
la loi 96 etc alors ce gouvernement là
tard à faire ces nominations là et ça
politiquement je dis pas que ça va
influencer un vote je pose certaines que
la population
et si sensible à cela mais quand un juge
la course près nous dit éradie et redit
que ça entache la confiance ça entache
l'accessibilité à la justice je pense
qu'il faut y proteste attention et j'ai
toujours de la difficulté à comprendre
comment ça se fait que Monsieur Trudeau
que son gouvernement
n'accélère pas le processus monsieur le
métisse matin du 2 choses la diversité
c'est important alors je pense qu'ils
vont mettre l'accent là-dessus même si
on a déjà nommé récemment une juge
autochtone et nous ce qu'on va
surveiller c'est effectivement le
bilinguisme et s'assurer que le ou la
juge qui seront nommés auront non
seulement une bonne compréhension mais
une capacité de s'exprimer en français
et pas adopté encore voilà l'obligation
formelle n'est pas le reçu Michel je
suis d'accord avec toi j'ai hâte de voir
s'ils vont aller avec le principe de
leur loi qu'elle soit ou non adoptée
on s'attendrait à ce qu'il soit
conséquent non
il me semble ok cela dit Jean-François
géographiquement faut que ce soit on
présume un juge de l'Ouest parce que
Monsieur Brown venait de l'Alberta alors
est-ce que c'est possible de trouver au
Canada un juge de l'Ouest bilingue puis
quand on dit bilingue c'est capable
d'entendre des causes à la fois en
français en anglais c'est pas toujours
pas toujours évident
des causes où il y a beaucoup de détails
puis des termes techniques enfin est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est possible
les problèmes c'est que le bassin est
très restreint c'est ça
mais là tu es obligé de le prendre
celui-là ou celle là alors que si tu
avais pas le critère du bilingus tu
pourrais choisir entre je sais pas 20 ou
30 personnes qui dans la magistrature
sont rendus à ce niveau-là
nous dire que c'est un mauvais critère
le bilingus
je comme étant indépendantiste je trouve
que notre présence impose à cet autre
nation qui n'est pas bilingue des
obligations qui les contraignent
énormément alors tant qu'il nous met pas
dehors c'est des contraintes avec
lesquelles il doit vivre mais
effectivement il faut accepter le fait
que c'est une énorme contrainte qu'on
leur impose parce que dans la vie
normale de tous ces juristes et ils
n'ont pas de raison de développer une
capacité linguistique en français qu'il
devienne nécessaire lorsqu'il arrive à
la Cour suprême mais bon l'autre critère
important c'est est-ce qu'ils vont
trouver quelqu'un qui est pas allé dans
un bar à Las Vegas de creuser une face
puis qui a eu deux coups de foin dans le
visage parce que moi je reviens à ça
c'est que franchement il y a aucune
raison objective dans notre connaissance
du dossier qui qui justifie que ce juge
de 56 ans se retire
voulait pas s'en vanter ce qui était pas
question qui appelle la police alors
toute cette histoire là on peut dire on
peut débattre de de son imprudence ou
quoi que ce soit moi je pense que c'est
un homme de certains d'âge qui voulait
creuser ce soir-là puis qui avait bu
puis c'est pas c'est pas dans le Code
criminel puis c'est même pas dans le
code d'éthique c'est bon ben écoute
c'est pas une bonne soirée qui s'est
passé ça ne dit rien sur sa capacité de
juger à la Cour suprême moi je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de penser que les
politiciens les maires de Toronto ou les
juges la course suprême dans leur temps
libre doivent être des saints de dire
non bon le maire de Tonton c'est
monsieur qui avait une relation avec une
de ces assistantes
dans la bonne direction c'est
l'intolérance caractérisée
jusqu'à parce qu'on était en 2023 ça
veut pas dire qu'on va tous devenir des
moines
mais sur le retour sur le plan politique
ceci présente une opportunité parce que
le juge Brown dans sa définition dans la
cour suprême il était aussi un juge
autonomiste respect des compétences des
provinces c'était en passant la dernière
nomination de Stephen Harper donc juste
avant sa démission il y avait cinq juges
à la Cour suprême nommée par Monsieur
Trudeau et quatre qui demeuraient de
l'époque de Monsieur un peu incluant le
juge en chef monsieur Wagner donc
monsieur Trudeau j'espère qu'il ne va
pas faire la même erreur que lors de son
avant-dernière nomination c'est-à-dire
par commencer à faire de la politique à
l'intérieur de la Cour suprême c'est à
dire nommer quelqu'un
issu d'une communauté c'est priorités
numéro un si on aboutit à un candidat ou
une candidate qui est issu d'une commune
communauté or anglophone francophone pas
de problème mais si on commence au tout
début à dire je vais avoir quelqu'un qui
tue de la communauté
noire ou quelqu'un de la communauté
indienne quelqu'un de la communauté
grecque mais c'est pas la place de la
Cour suprême si on veut faire ça mais
qu'on augmente la Cour suprême de 9 à 79
le nombre de juge à la Cour suprême du
Canada il faut trouver ce serait quoi ce
premier parce que Monsieur la médecine
diversité compétences mais c'est
peut-être pas l'ordre de priorité non je
pense que c'est l'heure de priorité pour
ce gouvernement et c'est là où ils font
erreur puis puis ce que j'entends des
échos des gens que je connais à la Cour
suprême
le juge le juge la Cour suprême le juge
a mal qui est pas nécessairement à sa
place à la l'extrême du Canada mais
monsieur Trudeau voulait nommer
quelqu'un
issu d'une certaine communauté donc
d'abord et avant tout la compétence sur
le plan juridique
deuxièmement la capacité d'entendre des
décors en anglais et en français et
ensuite tout le reste il y a le Sénat il
y a le Sénat pour faire pour faire ces
nominations partisanes est-ce que on
peut se concentrer à voir une Cour
suprême du Canada ou les 9 sur les 9
sont censés être des juges à la Cour
suprême du Canada d'accord
ça me rappelle tellement les discours
lorsqu'on a nommé les premières femmes à
la course
et c'était extrêmement important pour
moi de voir devoir arriver une femme
juge à la Cour suprême du Canada
un message profond de prétendre qu'il y
en a pas de disponible dans différentes
communautés
l'idée c'est que la Cour suprême du
Canada doit nous représenter et à ce
niveau là nous représenter aussi au
niveau de la qualité
doit nous représenter
oui elle doit représenter un
échantillonnage du Canada parce que
c'est le genre de cause qu'ils entendent
je m'excuse là mais moi femme blanche
entend des cas de réfugiés j'ai jamais
pratiqué là-dedans ça te prend des
spécialistes dans ces domaines-là alors
le juge en chef ou le juge en chef
lorsqu'elle est approchée par le Premier
ministre à l'exception de Steven un peu
qui se foutait carrément de l'opinion de
la juge en chef c'est eux des premiers
critères qui manquent qu'est-ce que tu
as besoin à ta cour il savent les
dossiers qui s'en viennent alors d'avoir
tous des civils au complet ou des gens
qui sont en commun sur des questions de
dommages intérêts quand au 18 causes de
réfugiés qui s'en viennent ou
d'environnement ou de si ça te prend des
spécialistes pour comprendre ces
choses-là alors c'est bon d'avoir un
spécialiste dans différents domaines
agents François qui dit on va peut-être
avoir un francophone ou qui est capable
de s'exprimer en français puis ça limite
le bassin je m'excuse mais ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que le Conseil de la
magistrature offre des cours et ils sont
bons au juges ils s'améliorent pourquoi
parce que comme moi si je vais avoir tel
job puis je sais que ça va me prendre
telle à faire pour l'obtenir ben je
m'améliore puis si tu sais qu'il faut
que tu connaisses les deux langues
officielles ben tu vas ben je trouve que
c'est en même temps ça les a réveillé
puis ont appris parce que je vous savais
aller plaider dans ta langue qu'elle
juge t'entends par la bouche d'un
interprète là c'est plateaux et pas le
même mais comme pas
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI